a friend is somebody who you hang out
with a friend is somebody who's like
always there for you when you need them
it's been not been as easy I think she
thinks it has been to just cut her out
of my life normal friendships don't come
with all the boys that comes of exes
being friends this absolutely cause
fights with me and my girlfriend but
it's not specifically personally about
Veronica it's just the insecurities of
society okay well Society
I'm sorry you go that way really running
good I think you're still mad about it
but I mean I don't have a time machine
to go back so what what do you want
resolution wise I want my friend back
I have always been there for you I
always thought that I would have you
there for me you've always said like
we're ride or die we have this marriage
pack that if we don't get married by the
time we're 50 like we're gonna get
married
the marriage pact was Tim's idea I
merely agreed to it and you're the one
who keeps adjusting the age because you
keep hitting the age and now that I'm
about to be 37 you're like never mind
it's when we both turn 50. yeah but it I
mean I didn't actually really think that
we were gonna be single yeah I thought
that that would be a reality but here we
are yeah
I'm sorry I still am your friend I still
care about you I am your friend let's
establish that I didn't realize I was
bothering you this badly
I appreciate that Tim and I hear you
saying that you want to be my friend but
literally I would like to see you acting
like my friend not just telling me
you're my friend
I never thought that I would be 37 and
single
and even though it was like a bit jokey
there was that part of me that knew that
by us making this marriage pact that we
would always be there for each other
but after everything that has happened
I don't know if this friendship can ever
be what it was before
[Music]